GOING TO MAKE AN
CTEDER ENT TO MOVE BOXES OFEW D
DOIS MAR-A-LO
RESIDENCE.IS AFT TRUMPEG TEAM  G
OME WAYS ONVESTIGATIONepte ABSOL
M PAMELAROCORDING TO A SOURCE S
SAYING THAT THCUNEEDED-A-LAGO AA
GO BACK TO THE RA
GOVENT
SO ALSO IMPORTANT EN THEY'RE .T
FO-LAGO
SHOWING ON SURVEILLANCE TAPE
BTH EIHN? S WRE PO THIS.
TH D?EQUES
>>orEMEMBENGR
IGATION RE I
ANTHG THION OF
ICE DEPARTMEBEEN LOOKING A THE
MOVINGS OUT OFT
TG M POTENT
ESTIGAOMETHING
OULD BECOMR ION INVESTIGN.HEHI
VERY IY FOR
PART OF WHAT THEY'RE
AT, JOFIC REPORTING, THANK
YOU.>>O TALK MORE IS, CNN GAD
NATID
FORMERENIOSECURITY COUNSEL
W SIGNIFICANT IS THIS NEWSER
OUT OF T WAY  THE VISION AN ORD
TRNGO TR L RAISES QUEIO
NUMBER OHI
METHINATBLA TRUMP EMPLOYEE AS T
POS THATOUBE
E AN EMP WHO IS RS
WALY
BOXES BUYB'TNOERE,OND
DOCUMENTS BTRUMP, HF SOMEONE IT
D
IS VIDVINCR S BEING MOVED, IAT
OPT OBSTRUCTION  I VIDEO EVIDENC
FERENTARE US TY
TH SUBPOENA, IF MEONE ISBETHWAR
HIM IN PARTICUR AN
FACILITATED TT.
RE'S THECT
WHO E VIHERE'S CREAND CORROBOR
DE, TESTIMONY THATT ORDER.
PIECE THA REPORTINGRAISES QUEST
ARE THEY CY EV TRUTHFUL
AT
TRUTHFUL?
THERE'RED
WHNVESTIGATORS HARE  SAMTHING. O
UNTHELECTI N
CNN POLLING OU MORNING
ABOUT WHERTHE CONTEST FOONGRESS
CNN SENIOR DA REPORTER H USSTANS
AND WE SEE NO CLEAADERBUAT6%BLIL
STILPOINRG.
50% FOR DEMOCRAT 47% FORICANS.
OIR DEMOCRATS.
HISTORICG, WHERE
OE
HIST
HOUSSE GW AT PLUS THRENET
CRATS.
BY TWO IN 201EN
ONHE NSN'T L01
2006, S LOOK 2
ELAT GOORESULT FOR REPUBCAE INEE
THEY NEED  TO E CORO
>> YES WPERHAPS. CRATS MT A TSU
>> WE MPLEE
CT DK
THD DETERMINCONTROL OF CONGRESF?
>> THI THE 5MPCTS AMONG LI SEE S
THE 2020 RESULT IN THESE
S THAT JOE BIDEN WONOINTS.SO A E
MATTERJO>>IT'S A PALPABLE SWIN
ALE FUNDAMENTALS A
LOT,THE THINGS THAT TEND
TO DRIVE MIDTERMD?
DIRECTIO 4 COMPETIVEISTRICIDER
POLICIES WOULD MOV RIGHT, TH
E
ABOU LE COUNTRY
TO BE TTER OFF
ENTHUSIASM.L IF E FUNDAMENTALS A
>>
Y ENTHUSIAST ABOUTYOUR MTEOWER.
BUT HERE'S TNOTE.
IT'S IT WA
OCTOBER OF4 OBER O
2010.
FORMIDTERM, SEEMSIK'RCLOSER
THAT THAN